[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
le ministre des affaires étrangères
d'ukraine mis trop collé boyle est avec
nous depuis kiev merci d'être avec nous
tout le plaisir est pour moi mais ce
monsieur le ministre la russie a annoncé
avoir frappé une usine de fabrication de
missiles près de kiev ce vendredi elle a
promis plus de frappes est ce que ça
veut dire que la guerre revient à kiev
où est ce que c'est une réponse au
naufrage de son navire amiral dans la
mer noire
la russie a déclenché cette guerre sans
provocation et ce pays a montré qu'il
n'avait pas besoin de raison légitime
pour frappé l'ukraine où que ce soit
il ne faut donc pas s'appuyer sur cette
logique selon laquelle la russie
riposterait aux actions de l'ukraine la
russie agit comme ceci car à elle est en
guerre une guerre agressive contre notre
pied à l'essai de nouvelles certaines
villes d'ukraine notamment qu'elles ont
été frappés par les bombardements
c'est vrai toutefois c'est la vie que
l'on a appris à vivre ces derniers mois
on revenir au naufrage du mot sera le
navire amiral de la flotte russe dans la
mer noire il a coulé jeudi les russes
ont dit que c'était un feu puis après le
mauvais temps vous dites que c'est une
frappe du craignent haine qui a causé
cela est ce que vous confirmez que c'est
bien cela
je vais vous dire une chose
l'ukraine n'a pas peur l'ukraine n'a pas
peur de se défendre et de frapper ce qui
représente une menace contre notre pays
et contre notre population
nous avons conscience que nous sommes en
guerre et que nous devons nous défendre
il est difficile pour la russie
d'admettre ce qui s'est passé sur son
navire amiral mais l'histoire révélera
la vérité et j'ai hâte de l'entendre
mais la vérité pour vous c'est qu'il
s'agissait bien d'une frappe de missile
ukrainienne
la vérité pour moi c'est que ce navire
amiral
ce navire amiral qui tiré des missiles
sur les villes ukrainiennes et qu'ils
tuaient des civils ukrainien repose
aujourd'hui au fond de la mer noire
voilà la vérité
humans and haas vous avez parlé des
frappes à kiev et dans d'autres villes
mais évidemment tous les regards sont
sur l'est du pays est ce que vous êtes
inquiet ce que vous craignez le pire que
vladimir poutine ne peut pas une
nouvelle fois perdre la face et qu'il
est prêt au pire
je pense que nous devons tous nous
arrêter de nous préoccuper de vladimir
poutine est de savoir s'il sauve la face
ou non il a décidé lui même d'attaquer
un pays souverain qui ne représentait
aucune menace
lui et son armée ont commis des
atrocités sans nom en ukraine ils ont
tué torturé violé
personne en europe a personne dans le
monde devrait élaborer sa politique pour
s'assurer que poutine sauve la face
la lumière poutine doit être vaincu à
tous les niveaux par tous les moyens
militairement politiquement
économiquement voilà l'objectif qui
devraient unir tous les pays qui
défendent la démocratie et l'état de
droit je veux en venir à la situation
dans la ville du sud-est à marioupol
évidemment la situation là bas est
extrêmement préoccupante
il y à des informations selon lesquelles
elle les russes ou les forces pro russes
sont en train de déterrer des cadavres
amène des crématoriums mobile 112 pour
effacer les traces de crime des crimes
qu'on a vu ailleurs à butch abordions
car est-ce que c'est l'information que
vous avez aussi
j'ai le regret de devoir confirmer
après les meurtres et les atrocités à
abuja et dans d'autres villes proches de
kiev les russes ont pris conscience du
fait qu'il devait couvrir leurs traces à
courir la trace de leurs primes dans
d'autres régions d'ukraine
je suis en contact avec une personne qui
était encore à rioufol j'ai reçu des
informations directement de cette
personne et je peux confirmer que
l'ampleur des crimes commis par les
russes à marioupol dépasse ce que l'on a
vu à bout de chats et à d'autres
endroits dans la région de kiev vous
êtes évidemment le diplomate en chef il
y à des négociations avec la russie on
ne sait pas si elles sont encore
vivantes est-ce qu'elle mène quelque
part étant donné tout ce qu'on voit sur
le terrain et ce qui semble se préparait
dans un futur proche dans l'est du pays
je vais vous le dire franchement
chaque journée de combats chaque
nouvelle maison détruite par les russes
chaque nouvelles victimes chez les
civils compliquer les discussions cela
rend les négociations toujours plus
difficile ces derniers jours nos experts
d'ukrainiens aller les experts russes se
sont rencontrés en visio conférence pour
discuter de différents éléments d'un
potentiel accord entre nos deux pays
toutefois aucun progrès n'a été fait
nous vous savons tous que c'est le
président poutine qui doit prendre les
décisions
et nous voyons le déploiement des forces
russes dans le donbass nous voyons que
j'admire poutine se consentir une
solution militaire puisque diplomatique
mais si ces négociations ne font pas de
progrès ciel continue à stagner est ce
qu'à un moment vous êtes prêt à dire on
arrête de négocier et on continue à se
battre
je ne pense pas que ce soit la manière
d'agir avec diplomatie en définitive
toutes les guerres se termine par un
accord et donc il faut continuer à
discuter mais nous comprenons tous que
l'avenir de cette guerre se décidera sur
le champ de bataille et pas autour de la
table des négociations
puisque nous parlons du champ de
bataille les etats-unis ont annoncé 800
millions d' aide militaire additionnel
des hélicoptères berouette surf et 40000
obus d'artillerie et il se dit qu'il ya
des discussions pour que l'ukraine
obtiennent des drones très sophistiqués
comme le reaper est ce que vous voyez
vraiment de plus en plus d'armes et des
armes de plus en plus sophistiqués
arriver en ukraine ça fait longtemps que
vous le demander de façon répétée
oui nous voyons de plus en plus de
livraisons d'armes à arriver en ukraine
et c'est la seule chose à faire pour nos
partenaires la guerre continue nous
défendons notre pays avec héroïsme nous
sacrifions nos vies est la meilleure
chose à faire pour nos partenaires c'est
nous offrir les armes dont nous avons
besoin c'est le meilleur accord que
l'ukraine a proposé au reste du monde
donnez-nous tout ce dont nous avons
besoin pour nous battre et nous ferons
le reste du travail nous nous battrons
nous nous battons sur notre territoire
pour que vous n'ayez pas à rentrer en
guerre je pense que c'est un accord
juste et j'encourage tous les pays y
compris la france à suivre l'exemple des
états unis et à augmenter les livraisons
d'armes vers l'ukraine et ces drones
dont j'ai parlé ce qu'ils vont être
livré à l'ukraine
il faut que je vérifie avec le ministère
de la défense j'ai vu
le dernier envoi le dernier soutien mais
pour moi le plus important c'est
l'artillerie de normes otan
dont nous avons énormément besoin à
l'est de l'ukraine
je ne me suis pas concentrée sur les
autres éléments mais nous avons vu que
les états unis ont envoyé de plus en
plus d'armes des armes de plus en plus
avancées et c'est important il n'ya pas
d'autre alternative
les membres de l'otan doivent suivre
l'exemple des états unis aient commencé
à envoyer des armes à l'ukraine en
parlant d'un pays membre de l'otan qu'en
est-il de l'allemagne
il ya eu une sorte de révolution en
allemagne
dans les premiers jours de la guerre
l'allemagne a totalement changé de
position en matière de politique sur
l'approvisionnement en armes avant le 24
février l'allemagne insisté sur le fait
qu'il n'enverrait jamais s d'armes en
ukraine que cela faisait partie de leur
politique en matière dames après le
début de la guerre ils nous ont envoyé
des armes et s'était appréciée mais ce
pays peut faire bien plus seuls
et nous attendons de la part du
gouvernement allemand qu'il adopte une
décision pour autoriser
l'approvisionnement en armes lourdes en
ukraine nous ne faisons pas que défendre
l'ukraine nous défendons le flanc est de
l'otan nous défendons l'europe et
l'allemagne doit comprendre que la
meilleure chose à faire c'est soutenir
l'ukraine par tous les moyens oui la
france vous avez une discussion avec
votre homologue français hier la france
a annoncé qu'elle allait ramener son
ambassade à kiev dans un futur proche
est-ce que cela vous satisfait et est ce
que vous êtes satisfait de l'aide
française à l'ukraine
oui je suis en contact régulier avec mon
homologue jean yves le drian le
président hélène qui s'entretient
régulièrement avec le président macron
nous avons un dialogue de qualité avec
la france un dialogue qui est appréciée
qui est bienvenu
je me réjouis de voir le retour de
l'ambassadeur français à kiev
l'ambassade va reprendre son travail à
partir de lundi c'est une très bonne
chose et nous encourageons les autres
pays à revenir à kiev a commencé à
travailler depuis la capitale et nous
travaillons également avec la france sur
l'approvisionnement en armes c'est un
des sujets dont nous parlons
nous souhaitons voir
plus de décisions prises par la france à
cet égard le rôle de la france est
également très important au sein de
l'union européenne en matière de
sanction imposer de nouvelles sanctions
contre la russie la france a mobilisé
beaucoup de soutien pour un prochain
train de sanctions le sixième train de
sanctions arrivent j'en ai discuté en
particulier avec les ministères français
il est important de mettre en place un
embargo sur le pétrole
pour que l'union européenne la nage est
plus de pétrole russe et arrête de
subventionner de la machine de guerre
russe
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que la
france est en faveur d'un embargo sur le
pétrole
j'ai l'impression que la france est
ouverte à la discussion à ce sujet c'est
une bonne chose
je ne pense pas qu'une décision finale
ait été prise pour le moment il faudra
certainement attendre le second tour des
élections présidentielles
avant de poursuivre nos discussions
mais je me félicite de voir la france
ouverte à cette idée
car si j'ai bien compris la france
aurait une solution pour
s'approvisionner en pétrole grâce à
d'autres pays
alors de la france il ya eu récemment
une dispute
sur la question du génocide
[Musique]
l'ukraine considère que la russie commet
un génocide
c'est la vie de joe biden c'est la vie
de justin trudeau mais le président
français n'est pas d'accord votre
président a dit que ces mots l'ont
profondément blessé
est-ce que vous pensez que emmanuel
macron effet cela pour laisser des
canaux de discussion ouvert avec
vladimir poutine et est ce que c'est la
bonne façon d'aborder cette question à
bord de ses chiens
vous savez avant le 24 février quand la
guerre a éclaté
on entendait toujours de paris mais même
d'autres capitales européennes telles
que berlin qu'il fallait parler discuter
avec poutine continuer à discuter ne pas
claquer la porte qu'il ne fallait pas
trop lui imposer deux choses et parce
qu'il ne fallait pas
le provoquer il fallait éviter l'
escalade et toute cette politique a
échoué elle a échoué car elle n'a pas
empêché poutine d'attaqué l'ukraine
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
demandons à berlin à paris à d'autres
capitales de revoir cette politique est
d'accepter le fait que
le moment est venu de s'unir le moment
est venu de s'opposer fermement à
poutine et à son pays
ce n'est pas le moment d'essayer de lui
plaire ou d'essayer de trouver un
terrain d'entente car il ne réagit pas
bien à ce genre de politique le
président mac on a fait énormément
d'efforts pour empêcher le président
poutine de déclencher cette bière mais
voilà où nous en sommes la guerre est là
et donc le moment est venu de changer
la proche française envers là aussi
donc en conclusion vous voudriez que la
france et son président appelle ce qui
se passe en ukraine un génocide
oui le moment est venu
je regrette profondément d'avoir à le
dire parce que cela arrive à mon peuple
à mon pays
mais plus longue sera cette guerre plus
il y aura de preuves que des actes de
haine ont été commis spécifiquement
contre les ukrainiens en tant que groupe
en tant que nation et donc en définitive
je pense que ces atrocités commises par
la russie seront considérés
juridiquement comme un génocide
mais ni trop cool et bah je vous
remercie d'avoir été notre invité sur
france 24
depuis kiev merci à vous d'avoir regardé
cet entretien
[Musique]